ich möchte dass sie wissen wie traurig
ich bin den besten job der welt
aufzugeben
ein rückzug auf raten also der
großbritannien jedenfalls noch nicht den
befreiungsschlag bringt auf den viele
menschen im land gehofft haben dürften
wie es nun weitergeht klären wir in
diesem zdf spezial zu dem ich sie sehr
herzlich begrüße was die älteste
demokratie der welt in diesen stunden
erlebt ist ja nicht weniger als ein
politisches beben und gewaltige
spannungen entladen sich allen voran der
aufgestaute frust über einen premier der
das gesetz bericht der wiederholt die
unwahrheit sagt und trotzdem glaubt
weitermachen zu können wie bisher bis
heute nachmittag isabel seminar über
einen steh auf politiker der nun wohl
liegen bleibt
es gab mal zeiten da war boris johnson
lustig der flog durch die luft setzte
sich komische mützen auf und streichelte
schafe für jeden gag zu haben
wir politiker sind dafür da dass man
sich über uns lustig machen kann das ist
wichtig machs gut
und sobald er sich nach oben eine
schnelle steile karriere war
bürgermeister von london führte die
brics it kampagne an dann ab 2016
außenminister unter theresa may in
diesem amt der erste politische fauxpas
die britische iranerin sergej radcliffe
wird bei einem besuch in teheran
festgenommen der vorwurf umsturz der
regierung johnson reagiert naiv die frau
habe nur journalismus unterrichtet hatte
sie nicht sie war verwaltungsangestellte
gary radcliffe wird es dieses jahr aus
dem iranischen gefängnis entlassen
pöbeln konnte er schon immer gut die
franzosen soll er einmal scheißkerle
genannt haben diplomatie geht anders
die liste der verfehlungen ist lang
falschaussagen über das einsparpotenzial
durch den eu austritt eine
untersuchungskommission über die
renovierung der eigenen wohnung partys
im lock down und privat stritt er sich
schon mal so laut mit seiner freundin
dass die nachbarn die polizei riefen
mehr als 40 mal hat er seine fraktion in
abstimmung geschickt um die
gesetzesvorhaben danach wieder
zurückzuziehen johnston hatte erst
anfang juni eine vertrauensfrage nur mit
mühe überstanden mehr als 40 prozent der
eigenen fraktion stimmte gegen ihren
regierungschef und dann eine riesen
rücktrittswelle von mitarbeitern der
regierung die luft wird dünn für boris
johnson er legt heute sein amt als
parteivorsitzender nieder als
premierminister will er erst mal
weitermachen
es ist der klare wille der konservativen
partei dass es einen neuen
parteivorsitzenden geben soll und damit
auch einen neuen premierminister
rückzug auf raten lustig ist das alles
schon lange nicht mehr
ja viel ernstes zu besprechen mit dem
britischen polizisten und historiker
professor timothy garton ash guten abend
nach berlin
guten abend ist das heute ein guter oder
ein schlechter tag für die britische
demokratie
das ende entspricht den mann
chaotisch
verlogen
unwürdig
unverschämt aber am ende der abgang von
boris johnson ist auch ein sehr guter
tag für großbritannien für die
demokratie und ich glaube auch für
europa ein abgang als parteichef aber
premierminister wird bei uns tanzen ja
noch einige wochen vielleicht sogar
monate bleiben was bedeutet das jetzt
für die regierungsfähigkeit des landes
gerade in diesen krisenzeiten
glauben wir dass überhaupt nicht ich
werde nächste woche ist er nicht mehr
premierminister es gibt ein amtierende
premierminister wir gehen in eine neue
phase ein neuer premierminister der
dennoch von den tories also aus der
konservativen partei kommen wird er kann
denn diese tief gespaltene partei die
großen probleme vor denen großbritannien
steht überhaupt noch bewältigen
also erstmal gibt es dann amtierender
prämien premierminister es muss ein
neuer premierminister gewählt werden die
probleme sind absolut gewaltig aber wir
bekommen hoffentlich eine seriöse
premierministerin oder premierminister
und ich sehe darin eine chance für den
land und würde ich sagen auch die chance
einen neuanfang in den beziehungen
zwischen großbritannien und die
europäische union wer könnte der diesen
neuanfang mit europa tatsächlich stimmen
innerhalb der konservativen partei auf
welchen ja nachfolger tippen sie
also es gibt etliche eine sehr schlechte
kandidatin und ärztlicher ziemlich guter
kandidaten im moment sieht es nach dem
heutigen verteidigungsminister ben
wallace aus eine sehr vernünftige man
sehr populär mit mit der parteibasis
der sich wirklich ausgezeichnet
verhalten in der unterstützung der
ukraine
die selbstheilungskräfte der britischen
demokratie das zeigt der heutige tag
scheinen zu funktionieren wenn auch spät
was muss letzte frage westminster aus
der causa boris johnson lernen
erstens dass man einen hoster planie zum
premierminister wählen soll oder zum
kanzler
und zweitens dass wir zu den alten guten
sitten der britischen demokratie zu tun
müssen und das ist wage ich zu behaupten
auch die wille des britischen volkes
sagt professor timothy garton ash der
glaubt dass boris johnson auch im amt
des premierminister ist noch wenige tage
überleben wird vielen dank für das
gespräch großer nach berlin
ja mit boris johnson wird ein britischer
premier abtreten mit dem auch der rest
europa so seine mühen hatte als der
partei und regierungschef wurde
versprach er den eu austritt
durchzuziehen koste es was es wolle der
notfalls auch ohne break setup kommen
und genau mit dieser alles oder nichts
mentalität ist ihm am ende das schon
unmöglich geglaubte gelungen die briten
verließen den klub mit einem handels
vertrag in der tasche johnson schieden
gewonnen zu haben aber europas vertrauen
hatte er verloren gunda krüger über ein
schwieriges verhältnis
frage eines britischen reporters hat die
eu-kommission extra champagner bestellt
um den abschied von boris johnson zu
feiern
der alkoholkonsum in der kommission ist
sehr begrenzt burgess in der komischen
so nüchtern der auftritte sind nicht
seine sache
was hatten sie darum gerungen boris und
die eu beziehungsstatus kompliziert der
eine wollte den dreck cit durchziehen
die andere dabei wenigstens die juwelen
retten die durchlässige grenze zwischen
nordirland und der republik irland und
den binnenmarkt der eu diesem zweck
sollten kontrollen dienen zwischen der
provinz und dem britischen mutterland
johnsons drohung den kompromiss zu
kündigen diskutierte die eu erst gestern
nüchtern
die andere seite verletzte mutwillig
internationale abkommen so kommen wir
nicht weiter
was wir dringend brauchen sind ruhige
konstruktive gespräche über die
umsetzung des nordirland protokolls
nicht politische spielchen oder
erpressung der anderen seite
die tür für großbritannien stehe offen
sagt der zuständige kommissar
jetzt ist es ein großbritannien durch
diese tür zu gehen mit den politischen
willen und echtem bemühen sind lösungen
in reichweite
es klang schon wie eine einladung an
johnsons nachfolger
diskutieren wir die europäische
perspektive auftritt haben die ins
regierungskrise mit der vize-präsidentin
des europa-parlaments katarina barley
guten abend
boris johnson ist also bald geschichte
viele briten atmen heute zumindest ein
bisschen auf sie auch
ja ich auch für uns europäerinnen und
europäer war boris johnson ein sehr
schwieriger partner der sich an zusagen
nicht gehalten hat der die eu immer als
sündenbock behandelt hat und für seine
innenpolitischen spielchen missbraucht
hat und ich kann nur hoffen dass das
beim nächsten premierminister dabei der
nächste
und trotzdem muss man sagen haben auch
die europäer boris johnson doch einiges
durchgehen lassen im zuge des blicks
seine wortbrüche seine tricks seine
taktierereien war europa im nachhinein
betrachtet zu nachsichtig mit ihm
nein europa hat sehr hart verhandelt und
einen tragfähigen kompromiss gefunden
ein abkommen was man umsetzen kann dann
wollte boris johnson manches davon nicht
umsetzen
natürlich nicht ich meine der exit ist
unbequem vor allen dingen für
großbritannien und er hat versucht sich
daraus zu finden die europäische union
ist da hart geblieben wir haben immer
wieder darauf bestanden dass alles
eingehalten werden muss gerade jetzt am
ende waren ziemlich hohe drohkulisse
aufgebaut worden deswegen ist es jetzt
gut wenn wir da einen frischen start
bekommen aber die geschichte des praxis
scheint noch nicht abgeschlossen zu sein
auch wenn johnson jetzt als parteichef
zurücktritt im britischen unterhaus gibt
es ja eine mehrheit die vereinbarungen
des praxis vertrages kippen will
stichwort nordirland protokoll auf wen
oder was setzen sie da ihre hoffnung
also vor allen dingen auf die menschen
in nordirland selbst die menschen in
nordirland haben gewählt vor nicht allzu
langer zeit und sie haben zum ersten mal
schimpfen die meisten stimmen gegeben
also nicht der protestantischen partei
die op die mit johnson mit
großbritannien enge verbindungen hat sie
wollen also etwas anderes
als diese tory regierung will und wenn
man auf die menschen in nord erhöht wird
dann
das verhältnis zwischen london und
brüssel ist ja bis zuletzt kann man
sagen schwierig geblieben was kann denn
europa beitragen damit es sich wirklich
kurzfristig mittelfristig verbessert
sehr viel beitragen können wir
eigentlich nicht über das hinaus was
bisher passiert
die europäische union war immer bereit
zu vernünftigen verhandlungen auch zu
kompromissen zum beispiel im bereich
medikamente sind auch welche gefunden
worden da ist auch die eu auf
uk zugegangen aber
viel spielraum zu manövrieren gibt es
einfach nicht und soll es johnson hat es
immer weiter getrieben bei nordirland
auch beim bei der anerkennung des
europäischen gerichtshofs als oberste
instanz in manchen fragen also er hat an
einigen punkten jetzt wirklich
konfliktpotenzial auf die spitze
getrieben wir müssen beiden strich unter
diese phase ziehen und noch mal neu
anfangen ich glaube darum geht es auf
beiden seiten jetzt die europäische
sicht auf die londoner erschütterungen
des tages katharina war danke für das
gespräch danke nach schwäbisch hall
und das gespräch haben wir vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
integrität ist ein pfeiler der
demokratie und keine abstrakte sache so
hat es der zurückgetreten der
gesundheitsminister david formuliert und
weil es boris johnson eben genau daran
mangelte muss ja nun wieder ausziehen
aus number 10 downing street das ist
zweifellos eine gute nachricht für das
ansehen großbritanniens in der welt und
umso wichtiger in diesen krisenzeiten
das war unser zdf spezial danke für ihr
interesse und noch einen schönen abend
auf wiedersehen